[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue ici à l'Assemblée
nationale et sur LCP pour cette
conférence de presse de rentrée de
l'Association des Journalistes
parlementaires avec aujourd'hui Yaël
Braun Pivet bonjour madame la présidente
de l'Assemblée nationale bonjour et
merci d'avoir accepté d'être notre
premier invité de la saison et de la
session
évidemment nous ne pouvons pas commencer
cette rencontre sans avoir une pensée
émue pour notre ami et confrère Gérard
Leclerc qui nous a quitté cet été merci
d'ailleurs d'avoir ouvert l'assemblée
nationale fin août pour qu'un hommage
puisse l'être rendu la session dernier
encore il était ici avec nous tous les
mercredis nous pensons évidemment à lui
et à sa famille quelques mots encore
pour vous indiquer que nous sommes
ensemble jusqu'à 13h vous l'avez compris
en direct sur la chaîne parlementaire et
sur le portail vidéo de l'Assemblée
nationale deux questions pour lancer la
discussion je vous en pose une Chantal
Didier vous en posera une autre et puis
ensuite le micro annulera dans la salle
l'an dernier ici même avec vous Madame
la Présidente nous disions que
l'Assemblée nationale telle que l'on
voulut les Français étaient à la fois
une chance pour le débat démocratique et
une responsabilité pour les députés de
la majorité et des oppositions à l'aune
de la session passé est-ce que vous
considérez que le contrat a été rempli
et surtout quels enseignements vous
tirez de la session précédente alors
qu'une nouvelle session s'ouvre pour que
pour que l'assemblée travaille mieux
encore au service des Français
déjà bonjour à tous et je suis ravie
d'être ici avec vous et je pense qu'on
est en train instaurer une tradition ça
commence à deux donc je suis ravie
d'ouvrir la session parlementaire en
votre compagnie et de pouvoir ainsi
répondre à vos questions
je pense que le contrat est rempli sur
le fond moins sur la forme c'est à dire
que sur le fond l'Assemblée nationale a
été au travail elle a produit de très
belles choses elle a adopté 92 textes
que ce soit des propositions de loi des
projets de loi ou des résolutions ou des
accords internationaux elle a rempli
pleinement son rôle avec de des
commissions d'enquête qui ont été
remarqués je pense à celle sur le
nucléaire notamment donc sur le fond je
pense que l'Assemblée nationale a
produit ce qu'elle devait produire et ça
n'était pas gagné d'avance puisque
d'aucun pensait que cette Assemblée
nationale serait complètement
incouvernable et que ce serait le chaos
permanent donc le fond est là sur la
forme ça n'y est pas le contenu n'est
pas malheureusement et cet été moi j'ai
été frappée par les témoignages des
Français qui venaient me voir quand il
me reconnaissait pour me dire mais
madame la Présidente comment faites-vous
pour finalement garder votre calme
devant une assemblée aussi turbulente
devant des parlementaires qui
s'investissent devant ce chahut et ça a
beaucoup choqué les Français et
malheureusement en termes d'image ils
n'ont un peu retenu que ça et donc et
l'image a même écrasé le fond et je
trouve que c'est dommage parce que
l'Assemblée nationale qui est celle
qu'on voulut les Français elle a
pleinement rempli ses missions et donc
c'est ça que moi j'aimerais maintenant
pour à l'ouverture de cette deuxième
année parlementaire faire vraiment vivre
c'est à dire montrer que la forme est au
niveau du fond et donc j'ai dit en
conférence des présidents je l'ai
rappelé au président de groupe je
souhaite que cette année n'est ni plus
de tenue moins d'invectives moins de
brouhaha moins de chahut alors vous me
direz ça a bien commencé hier après-midi
mais finalement ça n'a que peut durer et
la présidente de groupe a rappelé son
groupe à l'ordre très rapidement donc
voilà j'espère en tout cas qu'on
collectivement va réussir à installer un
autre climat pour donner une autre image
de l'Assemblée nationale à nos
compatriotes vous parlez pour ceux qui
n'ont pas suivi la séance de questions
gouvernement d'hier de quelques députés
écologistes qui ont arboré un t-shirt ce
qui est interdit t-shirt avec une
revendication ce qui est interdit dans
dans l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée Chantal
oui toujours pour ce poursuivre dans ce
climat est-ce pour cette raison pour que
le fond corresponde à la forme et puis
pour que l'assemblée reste
représentative de toutes les forces
qu'il la composent que vous avez enfin
la Conférence des Présidents a maintenu
hier le bureau inchangé c'est-à-dire il
y avait un débat est-ce que on garde les
vice-présidents
des parties extrêmes entre guillemets ce
qui concerne souvent le rassemblement
national mais aussi les insoumis donc
est-ce que vous estimez que c'est
absolument fondé dans l'option que vous
avez fait d'une assemblée qui travaille
sérieusement
oui tout à fait moi j'ai toujours
considéré que les
Français avaient choisi cette assemblée
que c'était pas une assemblée qui était
là par hasard et qu'ils avaient choisi
de confier leur voix en partie à des
parties extrêmes que ce soit de
l'extrême gauche ou d'extrême droite et
qu'il fallait respecter ce choix au sein
même de l'institution dans son
fonctionnement institutionnel donc la
place de chacun au sein de l'instance
collégiale la plus importante de
l'Assemblée nationale pour moi s'imposer
très vite j'ai fait par de ce choix et
de cette volonté aux autres
parlementaires et j'ai eu des échanges
pendant tout le mois de septembre avec
l'ensemble des présidents de groupe des
échanges individuels pour voir quelles
étaient leurs positions et pour essayer
de leur convaincre les convaincre en
leur disant que pour moi c'était ce
qu'il fallait faire pour la stabilité de
l'institution et je suis heureuse
qu'hier après-midi lorsque je les ai
réunis qu'il se soit tous rangés à cet
avis
ne veut pas dire que nous n'avons pas
des accords politiques et c'est très
important nous combattons nous nous
combattons politiquement mais il
n'empêche que chaque groupe a sa place
au sein de l'institution c'est ce qu'on
voulut les français si les Français
n'avaient pas voulu ceci il n'aurait pas
voté massivement tel qu'ils l'ont fait
et pour le rassemblement national et
pour la nups est-ce que cette position
laisse présager des futurs votes dans
les commissions aux écoles il y avait eu
un débat sur le précédent de la
commission des finances ce qu'il fallait
le maintenir pas le maintenir on va
est-ce qu'il remplissait son rôle
correctement est-ce que vous pensez que
votre enfin la position d'hier laisse
présager des résultats des commissions
alors nous nous sommes mis d'accord hier
également sur le statu quo au sein des
commissions permanentes donc la décision
qui a été prise hier par les présidents
de groupe réunis autour de moi c'est une
décision de statu quo global que ce soit
pour le bureau strictosensus de
l'Assemblée nationale ou pour les
commissions permanentes nous souhaitons
conserver cette stabilité dans nos
instances sans plus tarder on va passer
aux questions de la salle je crois qu'il
y en a beaucoup levé la main pensez bien
à vous présenter donner votre votre nom
et le média que vous représentez le cas
échéant comme on est retransmis la télé
ça permettra aux téléspectateurs de
mieux suivre notre rencontre
Stéphanie Lerouge de l'Agence France
Presse vous avez dit madame la
Présidente que les Français avaient été
choqués par le chahut à l'Assemblée ils
ont aussi retenu les nombreux 49-3 qui
sont intervenus l'année dernière
notamment sur le projet de loi retraite
le gouvernement va certainement activer
un 49-3 des aujourd'hui ou dès demain
pour l'adoption de la loi de
programmation
sur les finances publiques est-ce que
vous invitez à dédramatiser l'usage du
49-3 sur les textes budgétaires et
deuxième question
est-ce que vous pensez qu'à contrario il
ne faudrait pas utiliser le 49-3 sur le
projet de loi immigration comme le dit
certains responsables de la majorité
moi je fais partie de ceux qui pensent
que le 49-3 est un outil comme un autre
et que c'est un outil qui a été prévu
pour faire face à deux situations une
situation d'obstruction parlementaire et
une situation de majorité relative il a
été conçu dès l'origine en 1958 par les
constituants et j'observe que personne
malgré plus de 24 réforme de la
Constitution qu'elle soit portée par la
gauche ou par la droite personne n'a
jamais envisagé de supprimer cette
article de notre Constitution il a été
limité à travers le temps et la dernière
limitation datant de la réforme
constitutionnelle de 2008 donc moi je
considère que cet outil qui existe qui a
été prévu pour faire face à des
situations que l'on connaît aujourd'hui
est un outil qu'il doit être utilisé il
n'y a pas à le diaboliser pour autant je
fais aussi partie de ceux qui pensent
que le pas parlementaire est utile et
donc moi je ne
présage pas avant même que les débats
aient commencé à l'Assemblée nationale
de l'issue de ces débats je fais
toujours la confiance j'ai confiance
dans les parlementaires j'ai confiance
dans le gouvernement et l'année qui
vient de se passer me montre que sur
certains textes nous étions peu à penser
que nous obtiendrons des majorités nous
étions peu à penser que nous obtiendrons
des accords avec le Sénat et pour autant
nous avons trouvé les voies de passage
et les voies de passage nous les
trouvons parce que nous concertons parce
que nous parlementons parce que nos
débattons que nous proposons que nous
argumentons et en fait c'est là où le
Parlement joue juste pleinement son rôle
donc considérer l'issue d'un débat
parlementaire avant même qu'il n'ait
commencé ce n'est vraiment pas ma façon
d'envisager ni la politique ni ma
fonction
Brigitte boucher LCP plusieurs députés
de différents bords politiques défendent
l'idée de faire revenir la réserve
parlementaire vous vous avez souhaité la
supprimer quand vous étiez député lors
de la précédente législature est-ce que
vous pensez qu'on pourrait la faire
revenir pour aider les associations
c'est ce qu'ils disent avec plus de
transparence avec peut-être un regard du
déontologue où vous pensez que c'est
mieux ainsi
alors la réserve parlementaire pour
préciser c'était une somme d'argent que
qui était mise à la disposition de
chaque parlementaire député et sénateurs
et qui était destiné à financer
certains noms d'acteurs sur les
territoires de leur circonscription ou
pas
et en 2017 nous avons supprimé cette
réserve parlementaire dans les projets
de loi confiance
je suis je pense que c'est très sain de
ne pas permettre au parlementaire de
donner des subventions de façon
totalement discrétionnaire sur un
territoire quel qu'il soit ce n'est pas
le rôle du parlementaire mais vous savez
je pense que c'est une mauvaise réponse
à une bonne question et à une vraie
problématique on a une vraie
problématique qui est que
par l'effet successif de différentes
réformes on a terriblement éloigné le
parlementaire du terrain et on voit dans
de nombreuses études d'opinion que le
besoin de proximité et le premier besoin
exprimé par les Français vis-à-vis d'un
élu quel qu'il soit et donc il faut
trouver le moyen de retrouver cette
proximité du parlementaire sur le
territoire ça peut être par les faits de
de permanence citoyenne de
d'assembler citoyenne que des
parlementaires sur la sur leur
circonscription ça peut être augmenté
l'action de contrôle du parlementaire
d'évaluation des politiques publiques
remettre le parlementaire au cœur de la
relation avec le préfet il y a je crois
beaucoup de choses à inventer mais en
tout cas les vieilles recettes qui
seraient le retour de cumul des mandats
ou le retour de la réserve parlementaire
pour retrouver cette proximité ne me
semble pas être une bonne façon
d'appréhender les choses il faut
inventer le rôle du parlementaire sur le
terrain au 21e siècle et ne regardons
pas sans cesse dans le rétroviseur en se
disant c'était mieux avant je pense
qu'on est plus intelligent que ça on
peut trouver des meilleures façons de
faire évoluer le rôle du parlementaire
mais je pense que c'est un vrai sujet
que l'on doit tous adresser donc je
parlerai prochainement au président de
groupe sur cette question pour voir
comment on peut organiser le travail
ensemble parce que la question
est importante et je pense que avec les
taux d'abstention qu'on a aujourd'hui on
ne peut pas se satisfaire de la distance
qui se crée de plus en plus entre le
parlementaire et le citoyen donc
retrouver de la proximité oui par
l'utilisation de vieilles recettes non
Nicolas brisette pour la tribune
dimanche à propos des questions au
gouvernement
qui a beaucoup de reproches sont
adressées sur la forme quelle est la
part des reproches que vous adressez à
l'organisation générale que qui pourrait
être modifié donc et au comportement des
acteurs parce que je fais référence à
des périodes anciennes de l'histoire
maintenant pendant lesquelles le
gouvernement par exemple ne parlait que
lui donner bien davantage d'informations
en réponse aux questions des députés et
informations qui s'adressaient aussi aux
françaises et aux Français donc elle est
la part dans dans le dynamisme et la
qualité de ce moment quelle est la part
que vous attribuez à l'organisation même
et ce qui relève des acteurs merci
c'est c'est une très bonne question je
pense que le fond rejoint la forme c'est
et c'est tout à fait interdépendant je
pense qu'on a perdu en
réunissant les deux séances de questions
en une seule séance on a perdu du
dynamisme on a perdu on a perdu du
rythme malgré le fait qu'on ait créé un
droit de réponse c'est assez étrange et
ça n'était pas un effet qu'on avait
qu'on aurait pu imaginer et on voit très
clairement moi j'ai regardé les chiffres
on perd en gros 50% de tout c'est à dire
que je perds 50% de députés dans
l'hémicycle je perds 50% de ministres et
je perds 50% de tes spectateurs quoi
vous perdez 50% de téléspectateurs et
donc c'est pas satisfaisant c'est pour
ça que moi je m'interroge et je ne suis
je trouve que ça n'est pas satisfaisant
parce que justement l'exercice est
fondamental dans une démocratie c'est le
moment où le Parlement questionne le
gouvernement le gouvernement est
responsable devant le Parlement et donc
c'est l'acte de contrôle par excellence
et donc il faut lui redonner du
dynamisme ça va passer par la forme et
vous avez raison ça passe aussi par le
fond c'est à dire qualité des réponses
et parfois effectivement les réponses ne
sont pas à la hauteur et qualité des
questions aussi parfois les questions
sont très redondantes sont très
politiques et finalement ce qui
intéresse davantage le parlementaire
c'est plus la question que la réponse
donc je pense qu'effectivement on a une
responsabilité collective mais en tout
cas compte tenu de l'importance de cet
exercice démocratique je pense que
collectivement nous devons réfléchir à
sa revitalisation si la raison pour
laquelle je vais travailler avec les
présidents de groupe sur ce sujet dès la
semaine prochaine
pour Atlantico madame je voudrais
rebondir sur ce que vous aviez dit
précédemment votre réponse précédente
vous écartez totalement le retour du
cumul des mandats
écoutez si vous permettez parce que en
attendant de réinventer la nouvelle
forme de proximité je veux dire il y a
un grand gars et un grand vide
mais oui mais je en fait sur le cumul
des mandats après je l'écarte c'est mon
opinion et je ne suis pas seule à voter
la loi on est 577 et il y a le Sénat et
j'entends la position des uns et des
autres moi la position personnelle qui
est la mienne et qui est d'une constance
absolue c'est de considérer que les
Français attendent des élus qu'ils
soient à plein temps sur le mandat qu'on
leur confie et donc moi je considère que
il ne faut pas cumuler de fonction
exécutives en revanche on peut être élu
local et parlementaire j'ai fait les
comptes à l'Assemblée nationale il y a
50% des lieux locaux conseiller
départementaux conseillers régionaux
conseiller municipaux moi-même je suis
conseillère municipal mais je ne suis
pas adjoint au maire et je ne suis pas
mère
je considère que il ne faut pas mélanger
les fonctions exécutives donc le cumul
des mandats sur des fonctions exécutives
ne me pas ne me paraît pas être sain
mais je pense que il faut continuer à
avoir des élus locaux représentés au
Parlement et donc autoriser le cumul tel
qu'il existe aujourd'hui sur des
fonctions non exécutives pour rester un
tout petit peu sur la question des élus
vous plaidez dans la réponse que vous
avez envoyé au président de la
République après les rencontres de
Saint-Denis pour un sujet dont on parle
depuis longtemps à la création d'un
statut de l'élu
pourquoi et comment c'est vrai que c'est
un peu un serpent de mer les statut de
l'élu on en entend beaucoup parler on
avait un petit peu avancé lors de la
précédente mandature sur la loi
proximité engagement qui était porté par
Jacqueline Gouraud et qui avait été voté
très largement
pourquoi c'est important parce que on a
besoin
en France de personnes qui s'engagent on
a 35000 un peu plus de 35000 conseils
municipaux on a des conseils
départementaux conseils régionaux le
Parlement on a besoin de citoyens qui
prennent leur part qui prennent des
responsabilités qui acceptent de prendre
un mandat et on voit aujourd'hui qu'il y
a des freins à l'engagement qu'il y a
des freins à l'engagement et que ces
freins il faut les lever et il ne s'agit
pas d'avoir un statut privilégié il
s'agit juste de permettre à des citoyens
qui veulent s'engager de pouvoir le
faire sans que ça entraîne un sacrifice
qu'il soit personnel ou professionnel
qui soit trop important moi l'autre jour
pour vous donner un exemple très simple
je vais visiter un site dans ma
circonscription le président du site qui
est un élu maccueil et il me dit et bien
j'ai dû prendre une journée de plonger
pour pouvoir de mon entreprise puisque
je travaille dans le privé pour venir
vous accueillir et être présent lors de
cette visite et lors de cet échange
est-ce que c'est normal quand on est élu
de devoir sacrifier des jours de
vacances pour pouvoir juste remplir sa
mission d'élus moi je vois aujourd'hui
des parlementaires qui au bout d'un an
et demi après les élections législatives
sont toujours en difficulté pour se
réinsérer dans le monde professionnel
parce que il n'avait pas de parachute ou
parce que ils ont tout abandonné leur
cabinet d'avocats lorsqu'ils sont en
profession libérale leur emploi salarié
lorsqu'ils sont dans une entreprise
privée ça n'est pas normal on voit des
élus des petits élus locaux dans des
villages qui cumulent leur vie
professionnelle à plein temps plus leur
vie d'élus qui est un plein temps aussi
et donc il se sacrifie pour être élu ça
n'est pas possible donc il faut qu'on
regarde collectivement
et on y travaille à l'Assemblée la
ministre Dominique fort y travaille avec
l'AMF je pense que ça c'est un sujet sur
lequel nous devons avancer pour
permettre de faciliter l'engagement et
de faire en sorte que nous ayons de plus
en plus de nos concitoyens qui se disent
et bien chiche je m'engage dans la vie
de mon village dans ma ville dans la vie
de mon pays parce que nous avons besoin
de l'engagement de chacun
on a vu et on voit avec cette Assemblée
nationale que lors des derniers
législatives les Français ont
voulu que tous les courants politiques
du pays soient représentés à l'Assemblée
nationale avec cette situation de
majorité relative donc et des
oppositions très diverses qui sont qui
sont bien et fortement représentés
pour autant dans votre lettre au
président de la République toujours à la
suite des rencontres de Saint-Denis vous
continuez à estimer que la
proportionnelle reste une priorité
pourquoi et et proportionnelle ça veut
dire quelle dose est-ce que quelle
différence avec l'Assemblée nationale
qu'on a aujourd'hui ce mode de scrutin
permettrait-il en fait
j'ai envie de vous dire moi
l'Assemblée nationale telle qu'elle
existe
me semble être très représentatif des
Français
et ce que je souhaiterais c'est que elle
à l'avenir les futurs assemblées
nationales puissent continuer à être
aussi représentatif des Français que
celle-ci l'est alors c'est vrai que
celle-ci l'a été au scrutin majoritaire
mais nul ne dit qu'elle le sera demain
et c'est la raison pour laquelle moi je
suis assez favorable à ce qu'on
introduise une dose de proportionnelle
dans notre mode de scrutin un peu à
l'instar du mode de scrutin des
sénateurs qui sur les départements dans
lesquels il n'y a il n'y a je crois
trois sénateurs on est en scrutin
majoritaire et après on passe un scrutin
proportionnel moi je trouve que ce
système mixte permettrait de garder le
lien et un scrutin majoritaire sur la
plupart de nos départements et sur les
départements très peuplés tels que le
mien les Yvelines telles que les
Bouches-du-Rhône Paris les départements
franciliens et notamment du Nord etc on
pourrait être sur un scrutin
conventionnelle moi je trouve que ça ça
se regarde et ça permettrait avec cette
dose importante de proportionnelle de
permettre d'avoir une Assemblée
nationale qui représente pleinement les
Français dans la complétu de leur
opinion politique
vous l'avez dit plusieurs fois pour vous
évidemment la démocratie représentative
et essentielle pour autant vous
considérez que
réussir à instaurer une forme de
complémentarité avec la démocratie
directe notamment les les référendum
quel sujet au cours des des prochains
mois pourraient selon vous s'appliquer à
ce type de consultation moi je pense
fondamentalement qu'il faut qu'on
travaille collectivement à renouer le
lien avec les Français et à revivifier
notre démocratie on a une vie
démocratique malheureusement avec les
taux d'abstention qui se dévitalisent et
on ne peut pas s'en satisfaire et donc
pour cela moi je pense qu'il y a deux
voies d'action et il y en a probablement
d'autres mais en tout cas de voies
importantes à mes yeux d'une part
revivifier la démocratie représentative
d'où je pense la place importante et
peut-être
renforcer davantage les pouvoirs du
Parlement pour avoir une démocratie
représentative qui soit vraiment
pleinement représentatif de français
pleinement dans ses missions et
parallèlement revivifier la parole
citoyenne et leur permettre à nos
concitoyens de s'exprimer directement
sur un certain nombre de sujets d'où mon
plaidoyer pour qu'il y ait davantage de
consultations citoyenne davantage de
référendum j'avais évoqué deux sujets
qui étaient le SNU l'autre était la fin
de vie ça peut être tout autre sujet il
me semble que le critère c'est de
trouver des sujets qui intéressent
directement nos concitoyens il faut
vraiment que le pays puisse s'emparer
d'un débat qui les concerne et donc je
crois que ces deux sujets que j'ai
évoqués pourraient très bien faire
l'objet de référendum il y en a
probablement d'autres en tout cas à
créer du débat dans le pays et donner
aux citoyens la capacité de décider je
pense que ça serait très simple et ça
participerait à revivifier notre
démocratie certains de mon un référendum
sur l'immigration c'est c'est pas votre
cas pour vous ça n'est pas un bon sujet
de référendum
alors je pense que en fait le cas précis
sur les migration c'est que a priori ça
ne rentre pas dans le champ de l'article
11 et lorsque l'on parle de référendum
se dire que d'abord on va modifier le
champ pour pouvoir utiliser l'outil je
suis assez perplexe je préférais qu'on
ne l'utilise déjà l'outil qu'on a
aujourd'hui et puis après on peut se
poser la question de savoir si on en
modifie le champ parlons d'outils vous
avez été interrogé tout à l'heure par
Stéphanie le rouge de l'AFP sur le 49-3
évidemment sur le budget majorité aux
positions s'attendent à ce que le
gouvernement utilise le 49-3 puisque
traditionnellement et sauf surprise la
majorité vote le budget les oppositions
votre contre en revanche certains
s'interrogent sur le moment et la façon
du 49-3 et notamment avec la
préoccupation que le débat parlementaire
puisse avoir lieu que ce soit pas un
49-3 trop rapide et ensuite que le
Parlement soit entendu d'une certaine
façon par le gouvernement avec le
gouvernement lorsqu'il utilise le 49-3
tienne compte d'un certain nombre de
d'amendement qui aurait pu être voté au
cours du débat parlementaire vous vous
lancez cet appel vous aussi alors on a
échangé beaucoup échangé sur la question
de l'organisation de la discussion
budgétaire des échanges avec les
présidents de groupe avec le
gouvernement et bien sûr moi j'ai
échangé directement avec le président de
la commission des finances
et l'organisation que nous avons retenue
en conférence de président est issu de
ce dialogue entre les différents
présidents de groupe avec le
gouvernement etc donc je pense que la
solution que nous avons arrêté qui est
de fixer des jours de séances
prévisibles pour chaque mission
budgétaire et une c'est une solution qui
est consensuelle qui a été et qui est
issu du dialogue donc je pense que ça
c'est une bonne chose deuxièmement le
ministre du Budget a réinitier ce qu'il
a appelé le dialogue de Bercy et donc le
budget a fait l'objet de cette phase de
concertation avec l'ensemble des groupes
politiques en amont et ensuite
effectivement mais comme l'année
dernière il faut que la discussion
parlementaire permettent d'avancer sur
un certain nombre de sujets pour
qu'elles ne soient pas
inutile même si le gouvernement faisait
le choix d'utiliser le 49-3 donc vous
voyez bien dialogue en amont utilité de
la discussion parlementaire et dialogue
et concertation autour de l'organisation
même des débats c'est ce que nous avons
fait et donc je pense que la solution
retenue est assez satisfaisante
vous avez instauré des semaines dans
lesquelles on examine des propositions
de loi transpartisanes comment
appréhendez-vous la façon dont vous
inscrirez à l'ordre du jour on pourrait
imaginer par exemple que la proposition
de loi sur la réserve parlementaire qui
est aujourd'hui porté par un certain
nombre de députés soit examinés à cette
occasion même si vous n'y êtes à titre
personnel pas favorable
heureusement que on inscrit pas à
l'ordre du jour des textes en tout cas
que je ne suis pas décisionnaire en
fonction de mes opinions politiques ça
serait tragique
les semaines transparte tisane déjà moi
j'en suis très heureuse c'est quelque
chose qui marche bien et qui était très
innovant mais qui je crois correspond à
l'assemblée que nous avons et qui
correspond profondément à ce pourquoi
moi je me suis engagée en politique moi
je me suis engagée en politique parce
que je croyais je crois et je crois et
demain au dépassement d'écrivage et à
notre capacité de travailler ensemble
sur des sujets déterminés et les
semaines transpartisanes sont finalement
le reflet de cela et c'est un travail en
commun mené par des parlementaires de
tout bord politique qui aboutit à des
propositions de loi et donc c'est une
initiative que j'avais lancée en début
de session et que nous allons renouveler
pour cette session parlementaire j'ai
une réunion aussi avec les présidents de
groupe pour voir quels seront les
modalités d'inscription pour les
semaines transpartisanes ce qui est sûr
c'est que la Conférence des Présidents
est souveraine pour fixer l'ordre du
jour de ces semaines de l'assemblée et
donc les textes qui ont reçu un certain
nombre de signatures
peuvent être éligibles aux semaines
transpartisanes mais ça n'est pas le
nombre de signatures qui fait une
inscription d'office en semaine
transpartisane c'est une décision
souveraine de la Conférence des
Présidents et donc par la voix des
présidents de groupe
Frédéric Delpech pour lcit TF1 pour
revenir sur le budget
Bruno Le Maire a été assez clair en
disant que ces pistes de d'économie de
16 milliards doivent être respectés à
l'issue du vote ça veut dire qu'il est
assez peu de marge d'après le ministre
de l'Économie est-ce que vous vous êtes
d'accord avec ce point de départ sur le
fait de ne pas alourdir la charge
pendant le débat et puis deuxième
question toujours par rapport à Bruno Le
Maire même si vous y avez déjà un peu
répondu ce matin il propose de repousser
le calendrier d'applications de la fin
des passoires thermiques pour les
locations parce que et bien les Français
semble-t-il ils sont assez sont un peu
étranglés par le sujet et vous vous ne
souhaitez pas ce report semble-t-il
sur
ce deuxième point effectivement moi je
pense que il ne faut pas dégrader
l'ambition écologique qui est la nôtre
et
je pense que il n'est pas très
qui
que nous ne pouvons pas faire sans cesse
compte tenu des de l'évolution des
circonstances des allers-retours sur ce
que l'on vote donc moi je suis assez
réticente à revenir sur ce que nous
avions voté et je suis assez réticente
sur le fait de dégrader
l'ambition écologique qui est la nôtre
maintenant je j'entends les arguments de
Bruno Le Maire et nous en discuterons au
Parlement mais la position personnelle
qui est la mienne et celle là maintenant
sur les économies
qui figurent dans le budget présenté par
le gouvernement je pense que la
trajectoire d'économie elle est
essentielle et elle est nécessaire et
nous avons le devoir de tenir ce cap là
et donc la trajectoire proposée par
Bruno Le Maire me semble être la bonne
nous devons poursuivre l'objectif de de
sécurisation de notre budget de
sécurisation de nos finances publiques
nous avons des taux d'intérêt qui ont
considérablement augmenté nous avons une
dette considérable également nous ne
pouvons pas être continué à creuser le
déficit et donc il faut avoir une
trajectoire de finances publiques
responsable et c'est ce qu'a présenté
Bruno Le Maire et c'est ce qu'il
présentera et défendra dans l'hémicycle
et en cela je suis parfaitement en phase
oui je voudrais revenir sur les
passoires thermiques lorsqu'il y a des
allers-retours du gouvernement sur des
textes de loi votée comme ça il y en a
eu plusieurs est-ce que c'est la
signifie que les études d'impact sont
mauvaises c'est à dire qu'en fait quand
on a les parlementaires ont voté ils ont
pas mesuré les conséquences que cela
pouvait entraîner alors on a on a deux
choses et c'est vrai que c'est un autre
serpent de mer les études d'impact au
Parlement parce que souvent on se plaint
de leur incomplétude et de leur de leur
faible qualité je suis pas complètement
d'accord les études d'impact sont
souvent très bien faites et très
complètes mais il y a la question de
l'étude d'impact et puis ensuite il y a
la question de l'évaluation de la loi
votée et on peut et il est très sain
d'évaluer ce que l'on vote mais il faut
quand même laisser le temps à une loi de
s'appliquer avant d'évaluer pour pouvoir
éventuellement corriger la loi que nous
avons voté pour être sûr que elle attend
bien ses objectifs etc donc donc étude
d'impact de bonne qualité qui doit
pouvoir s'améliorer encore meilleure
évaluation de la loi
votée ça c'est certain après il faut
laisser un peu de temps autant j'ai
envie de dire mais je pense que en fait
on a on a vraiment besoin et ça c'est un
souci collectif d'avoir de travailler à
cette amélioration de la qualité de la
loi donc en amont pendant et en aval et
en surveillant les décrets d'application
alors en surveillant les décrets
d'application évidemment vous savez que
normalement ça aussi c'est un peu une
légende urbaine
on considère que les délais
d'application on dit souvent que les
décrets d'application ne sont pas pris
dans les temps
ça n'est pas alors ça c'est un autre
sujet dans les temps ils sont pris dans
les temps moi j'ai en tout cas quand
j'étais présidentE de commission des
lois je voyais qu'ils étaient pris dans
les temps à 95% donc c'est et les
présidents de commission font un suivi
très fin des décrets d'applications
après il y a est-ce que le décret
d'application est bien conforme à la loi
votée par le Parlement et à la volonté
du législateur ça c'est un autre sujet
et
on a notamment un exemple qui est assez
célèbre sur les représentants d'intérêt
et pour lequel moi quand j'étais
président de commission j'avais alerté à
plusieurs reprises le ministre
considérant que le décrenne n'était pas
conforme à la volonté du législateur et
la commission des lois à travers Gilles
Legendre et Cécile huntermeyer viennent
de retravailler sur cette question dans
le cas d'une mission d'information qui a
donné lieu à au dépôt d'une proposition
de loi que je trouve fort intéressante
pour que justement
le décret soit conforme à la volonté du
législateur vous voyez l'intérêt de
suivre d'évaluer pour pouvoir après
corriger si nécessaire et j'espère
qu'elle sera inscrite sur une semaine
transpartisane
oui vous parliez tout à l'heure du
statut de l'élu la Haute autorité pour
la transparence de la vie publique va
très prochainement fêter ses dix ans
début octobre
qu'est-ce que vous des voies ont pu
s'élever plutôt en off pour dire que
trop transparence pouvait nuire à
l'engagement dans la vie publique
qu'est-ce que vous pensez vous du
travail de la Haute autorité et est-ce
que vous avez un avis sur les demandes
formulées par son président Didier
Migaud à savoir la rédaction d'un code
de déontologie qui était promis par la
loi qui n'a jamais été écrit d'une part
et d'autre part la possibilité pour la
Haute Autorité d'avoir un pouvoir de
sanction propre
moi je trouve que la hatvp a pleinement
trouvé sa place dans notre vie publique
et que la fusion que nous avons décidé
avec la commission de déontologie à est
un vrai succès et là pleinement renforcé
dans ses missions donc moi je suis pas
de ceux qui considèrent que la
transparence et que la les pouvoirs de
vérification de la hatvp sont trop
importants il est fondamental
aujourd'hui que nos concitoyens n'est
strictement aucun doute sur la probité
de leurs élus et de leurs grands
responsables publics il ne faut qu'il
n'y ait aucun doute et la hatv qui
remplit très bien ses missions permet
justement à nos concitoyens de n'avoir
aucun doute
et donc moi je pense que elle elle a
trouvé sa place elle remplit ses
missions est-ce que il faut la doter de
pouvoir supplémentaire c'est quelque
chose qu'il faudra discuter dans ton a
déjà parlé parce qu'il y a le pouvoir de
sanction il y a aussi le pouvoir de de
la capacité à obtenir des informations
de façon directe qui était une autre
demande de Didier Migaud tout ça ce
regarde mais en tout cas moi je ne suis
pas de ceux qui considèrent que c'est
trop
Brigitte boucher LCP il y a un texte de
loi sur l'endométriose qui arrive le 12
octobre à l'Assemblée nationale à
l'initiative du rassemblement national
Bérengère Couillard la secrétaire d'État
en charge de l'égalité homme-femme s'est
prononcé pour qu'il y ait un décret du
gouvernement avant l'examen de ce texte
de loi est-ce que vous vous y êtes
favorable également à défaut de décret
que doit faire la majorité est-ce
qu'elle doit voter pour pour ce texte ou
au contraire s'abstenir et comment
l'expliquer aux Français
c'est un sujet qui est majeur et qui
concerne beaucoup de nos concitoyennes
et qui qui ont des histoires très
douloureuses parfois avec avec cette
maladie
moi je pense que le Président de la
République a lancé un grand plan autour
de l'endométriose avec beaucoup
d'investissement et beaucoup de mesures
avec et on a fait beaucoup de progrès
ces derniers mois sur sur ce sujet
il ne s'agit pas voilà peu importe
finalement
quel est le véhicule en terme législatif
moi je pense que si un décret sur un
point précis suffit c'est beaucoup plus
rapide c'est beaucoup plus efficace et
ça évidemment ma préférence mais en tout
cas le Gouvernement sur ce plan agit
agit fort agit rapidement et c'est ce
qui moi m'importe pour toutes ces femmes
qui sont victimes d'endométriose après
que certains en face un sujet politique
au sein d'une niche ça ça les regarde
mais en tout cas moi c'est pas ma façon
de faire de la politique
Frédéric Aziza radiologie partant de ce
que vous avez dit sur la science de
question est-ce que vous êtes favorable
à ce qu'on revienne à deux séances en
tout cas quand on lance le débat et
deuxième question c'est Bruno Le Maire
qui vient de dire à propos des des
passoires thermiques pas question de
modifier le calendrier mais il faut
réfléchir à comment être plus simple et
plus clair est-ce que ce que vous pensez
aussi
alors on est d'accord pas question de
modifier le calendrier je pense que on
est on a tous dans la majorité qui est
qui est la nôtre le souhait de ne pas
dégrader notre ambition écologique voir
de l'accélérer et de la rendre encore
plus ambitieuse donc on se on se rejoint
évidemment sur ce point sur les les
faire quelque chose de plus simple et
plus facile pour nos compatriotes
évidemment on voit bien que sur un très
nombre de très nombreux sujets on
n'arrive pas en fait à atteindre les
objectifs qui sont les nôtres à cause de
trop de complexité et donc plus on
simplifiera les procédures plus on fera
quels sont que les dispositifs que l'on
met en place sont seront accessibles
mieux ce sera pour pour nous tous
pour les questions au Gouvernement c'est
une piste refaire deux séances
c'est c'est mais il ne faudrait pas que
ce soit de séances comme avant et de
séances identiques donc moi je réfléchis
à un certain à l'instar d'un certain
nombre de parlements étrangers à faire
si on revient si c'est ce choix qui est
retenu par les présidents de groupe à
différencier les séances pour avoir un
exercice de contrôle qui soit différent
sur les deux séances et sur la semaine
jacques Hébert indépendant quel a été
votre réaction lorsque s'adressant à un
de ses collègues qui plus est le patron
du Parti communiste une députée de la
France insoumise soutenue par Jean-Luc
Mélenchon a écrit je cite l'histoire se
répète il y a du Doriot dans Russell
moi je passe j'ai beaucoup de choses à
faire vous savez en tant que président
de l'Assemblée nationale et donc je ne
commande pas les propos des uns et des
autres c'est pas mon sujet
le temps que le micro arrive pour la
question suivante
bonjour Xavier Robert et Hervé
Nouvelle-Calédonie l'Union calédonienne
partie indépendante
a décidé de refuser tout contact toute
discussion avec l'État son sénateur
nouvellement élu dimanche Robert revis a
été très clair nous allons prendre notre
temps alors le président de la
République a vous l'a dit il a dit aussi
à Gérard Larcher il veut une réforme de
la Constitution pour la
Nouvelle-Calédonie au début de l'année
prochaine compte tenu de ces positions
radicales est-ce que ce calendrier vous
paraît possible jouable
alors la Nouvelle Calédonie est d'un
sujet que vous connaissez bien et qui
est d'une complexité folle
nous à l'Assemblée nationale nous avons
créé un groupe de contact avec
l'ensemble des présidents de groupe et
le président de la délégation outre-mer
et nous avons réalisé un certain nombre
d'auditions et nous allons les
poursuivre et je rencontre à chaque fois
qu'il m'est possible de le faire chaque
partie prenante
je pense que la solution que nous devons
trouver doit nécessairement partir de
nouvelles Calédonie et il est impératif
que
nous arrivions à parvenir à un accord
donc c'est ces déclarations que vous
citez
me désole parce que je sais que chacun
là-bas est partisans du dialogue et que
ce dialogue doit nous permettre
d'aboutir à un compromis sur ce dossier
notamment sur les listes électorales
puisque s'il y a une réforme
constitutionnelle c'est ce point du
corps électoral qui devrait en faire
partie et donc il faut dialoguer et moi
j'aurais plaisir à rencontrer ce
sénateur nouvellement élu pour ce faire
je pense que on a besoin de la
participation de tous alors prendre son
temps oui mais il y a aussi des
échéances il y a aussi des échéances
électorales locales en
Nouvelle-Calédonie et donc il ne
faudrait pas
que nous il faut prendre son temps mais
il faut pas le perdre pour résumer ma
pensée
oui bonjour Jean-Michel Lamy nouvelle
économiste l'Assemblée nationale
peut-elle avoir un rôle international
une dimension internationale vous avez
récemment participé à un G7 des
parlements comment vous avez perçu le
soutien l'Ukraine et envisagez-vous des
je sais pas des
comment dire des participations
avec l'ensemble des parlements sur des
initiatives diverses ou autres
l'Assemblée nationale à travers sa
première vice-présidente qui est Valérie
rabot en charge des activités
internationales moi-même et tous les
groupes d'amitié que nous avons à une
intense activité diplomatique qui est
extrêmement
utile qui nous permet de nouer des liens
très étroits avec un grand nombre de
pays et qui nous permettent aussi de
porter la voix de la France d'une façon
différente complémentaire de celle de
l'exécutif mais différentes et vous
voyez
demain matin je m'envole pour Dublin
pour participer l'Assemblée
parlementaire du Conseil de l'Europe et
nous parlerons notamment de la question
démocratique donc à Tokyo nous avons
parlé du crâne et d'environnement et je
pense que c'est très important de
coordonner aussi nos actions niveau
parlementaires et sur le sujet de
l'Ukraine spécifiquement moi je suis en
contact constant avec mon homologue
rosslan Stefan show président de la Rada
je le verrai d'ailleurs à Dublin dès
demain et les actions des parlements en
ce qu'il soutiennent les actions
résolues de leur gouvernement sont
fondamentales sont fondamentales que ce
soit sur le plan politique diplomatique
mais aussi sur le plan des sanctions sur
le plan militaire nous avons nos
gouvernements ont besoin d'avoir les
Parlement avec eux sur le soutien
l'Ukraine et je peux vous dire que j'ai
cette à Tokyo c'est un soutien unanime
sans aucune discussion qu'on manifestait
les pays du G7 envers le crâne
François Gervais ils ont politique le
président de la République a mis en
exergue la transition écologique
est-ce que le est-ce que vous seriez
favorable à une loi de programmation
pluriannuelle qui préciserait les
financements dans différents secteurs
comme c'est le cas pour la défense
nationale par exemple
moi j'aime beaucoup l'idée des lois de
programmation je trouve que ça nous
permet d'avoir une vision sur le long
terme qui va être discuté au Parlement
et donc vous citez la loi de
programmation militaire mais on a fait
une loi votée une loi de programmation
pour la justice on a voté une loi de
programmation pour la sécurité
intérieure certains aimeraient qu'on ait
des débats de programmation sur la santé
notamment c'était le sens d'une
interrogation d'une décuvegie posée par
le modem hier je pense que c'est un vrai
une vraie bonne façon d'appréhender la
politique de s'inscrire dans le temps
long donc d'avoir un débat d'avoir une
loi de programmation qui fixe un cadre à
long terme sur une politique publique
que nous menons et qui s'inscrit qui
plus est forcément sur du long terme
comme l'environnement je pense que c'est
une très bonne idée
le micro
juste un petit ajout à ce que vous venez
dire est-ce que ça ça serait aussi
important pour ce qui concerne la
transition énergétique une grande c'est
actuellement demandée il y a des
scientifiques qu'ils demandent beaucoup
il pense qu'on peut presque faire un
projet Manhattan vous savez comme pour
la fabrication de la bombe atomique bon
très bien mais sur le nucléaire parce
que il y a des petites propositions
par-ci par là qui semblent un peu juste
par rapport à l'enjeu et puis on a aussi
les Verts qui sont le parti qui serait
chargé de voilà de promouvoir ça et
c'est pas ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
c'est très conflictuel alors est-ce que
vous vous êtes favorable à ce projet là
pour la transition énergétique je pense
que ma réponse a englobait en fait la
transition énergétique avec les
questions environnement je pense qu'il
faut en fait plus on a des bas mieux
c'est
plus on n'aimait pas surtout sur ces
questions
environnementales et énergétique qui
engagent le monde mais sans être aussi
pompeux qui engagent notre pays sur des
décennies et des décennies et c'est des
centaines de milliards d'investissements
lorsqu'on parle de notre parc nucléaire
ou donc ça engage des générations
entières et donc avoir une vision à long
terme et débattre de cette vision à long
terme que ce soit au Parlement ou avec
nos concitoyens me paraît être essentiel
le président de la République parle la
semaine prochaine je crois devant le
conseil
constitueutionnel où en êtes-vous de vos
réflexions dans ce domaine en matière de
d'institution vous aviez monté un groupe
de travail je crois et quels sont vous
vos éventuels propositions surtout s'il
y a une révision constitutionnelle l'an
prochain comme l'évoquer mon collègue
alors on évoquait une révision
constitutionnelle qui serait spécifique
à la nouvelle qu'elle est donnée nous ne
savons pas si elle s'inscrirait elle
pourrait s'inscrire dans une réforme
d'ampleur moi je pense que nous avons
besoin de revivifier notre démocratie je
le dis souvent et que ça passe notamment
par une réforme constitutionnelle mais
pas seulement donc il y a beaucoup de
sujets que nous pourrions aborder dans
le sein d'une réforme constitutionnelle
on parle de la modification du chant du
référendum on en a parlé tout à l'heure
l'article 11 savoir comment revivifie le
référendum d'initiative partagée la
participation citoyenne mais on a
beaucoup d'autres sujets dans une
éventuelle une forme constitutionnelle
qui vont de l'indépendance de la justice
à la constitutionnalisation de
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse à
la question de l'environnement à
l'article 1 tel qu'il était proposé dans
la convention citoyenne à la question de
la décentralisation de nos outre-mer
donc c'est un champ qui est
potentiellement extrêmement vaste et
pour lequel nous avons besoin d'un
accord politique et qui soit très large
puisque comme vous le savez il nous faut
une majorité des 3/5 puisque nous avons
besoin d'un vote dans les mêmes termes
par le Parlement puis après d'un vote
aux 3/5 donc le chemin est difficile le
chemin est difficile il est ardu ça
n'est pas une raison pour ne pas
l'emprunter et c'est la raison pour
laquelle moi j'ai réuni ces groupes de
travail que je souhaite qu'il reprenne
pour que nous puissions poursuivre nos
discussions il ne faut jamais renoncer
parce que je pense que c'est important
pour notre démocratie mais le chemin est
compliqué
journaliste très honoraires le dernier
le dernier
président de la République qui a été
Président de l'Assemblée nationale
c'était Vincent Auriol depuis aucun de
vos 14 prédécesseurs
n'a réussi à transformer son statut de
deuxième personnage de l'État en premier
personnage de l'État que quelques-uns
troisième quelques-uns la tentation
ça vendait le Maska fort Laurent Fabius
sans succès ma question est un peu
différente quand on est une jeune
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
comme vous quelle ambition peut-on avoir
et bien l'ambition de servir l'Assemblée
nationale qui est l'institution qui
représente le mieux les Français
le micro
ment a reculé le la loi qui devait
passer sur la fin de vie est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est quand même d'après les
Français c'est un sujet de société
essentielle près de 80% des citoyens
souhaitent qu'on en débatte comment
est-ce que l'Assemblée nationale peut
travailler dans ce sens et justement
parler d'un sujet de société et on a
l'impression que le gouvernement les
évite plutôt
alors déjà
personnellement je suis extrêmement
favorable à ce qu'on fasse évoluer la
législation sur la fin de vie et donc je
souhaite qu'il y ait un texte qui soit
adopté en la matière
au cours de ce quinquennat c'est mon
souhait et c'est une position politique
que justement que j'ai mûrement réfléchi
et qui me semble être nécessaire
comment l'assembler peut avancer sur ce
sujet alors l'Assemblée nationale a
évalué les lois classe néonetti il y a
une mission d'évaluation l'Assemblée
nationale a été
associée étroitement aux travaux
qu'amenaient
Agnès Firmin le Bodo la ministre en
charge de cette question pour préparer
la loi que le gouvernement va présenter
sur ce sujet en conseil des ministres à
l'automne et je souhaite que nous
puissions avancer sur ce sujet soit par
la voix d'un débat parlementaire ou par
la voix d'un référendum mais en tout cas
nos compatriotes nous le disent ils
souhaitent une évolution de façon très
majoritaire et donc il faut aller dans
ce sens là nous voyons que les
insuffisances de la loi actuelle c'est
une loi de liberté que nous devons voter
la liberté de choisir et il faut
permettre donc à chacun de nos
concitoyens de pouvoir librement choisir
sa fin de vie cela signifie également
lui permettre ou que ce soit sur le
territoire d'accéder pleinement aux
soins palliatifs ce n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui et donc l'ouverture d'un
nouveau droit de cette nouvelle liberté
doit également s'accompagner d'un
renforcement considérable de l'accès aux
soins palliatifs pour permettre à chacun
de choisir ou qu'il se trouve sur le
territoire de la République
parmi les autres sujets complexes mais
sur lequel sur lesquels les Français
attendent à la fois le gouvernement et
le Parlement il y a la question du
vieillissement bien vieillir il y a une
proposition de loi qui avait été
inscrite en fin de session dernier à
l'ordre du jour de l'Assemblée nationale
et qui n'a pas pu être débattu faute de
temps est-ce que
vous espérez est-ce que vous savez même
des assurances sur le fait que ce texte
soit réinscrit assez rapidement
peut-être des cet automne à l'ordre du
jour de l'Assemblée nationale je pense
que c'est en tout cas un texte qui est
en cours d'examen il reste on est à peu
près à mi-chemin dans l'examen du nombre
d'amendements il y avait un peu moins de
1000 amendements ils nous en reste un
peu plus de 400 examinés donc oui il
faut que ce texte soit réinscrit il est
important il il est vraiment voilà
nécessaire
utile il a été très travaillé par les
parlementaires il s'agit d'une
proposition de loi moi c'est un des
bienfaits cette première année de
mandature on a plus que doublé le nombre
de propositions de loi qui ont été
débattues dans l'hémicycle et qui ont
été soit qui sont en cours de navette ou
adoptés je trouve que c'est un fait très
signifiant et très positif pour le
Parlement et l'Assemblée nationale donc
je souhaite que ce texte revienne il y a
des discussions en cours pour voir à
quel moment on l'inscrira à l'ordre du
jour et peut-être effectivement à
l'automne ça fait partie des options qui
sont sur la table aujourd'hui dans
l'immédiat c'est le projet de loi pour
le plein emploi qui est débattu en ce
moment ces jours-ci et jusqu'à la
semaine prochaine dans l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée
il y a la question notamment de la
réforme du RSA qui est au centre des
débats l'objectif du gouvernement c'est
d'atteindre le plein emploi y compris en
accompagnant ceux qui sont le plus en
difficulté vers l'emploi mais la gauche
considère que cette réforme du RSA
risque de fragiliser encore plus ceux
qui sont déjà en difficulté la droite
elle au contraire est tent é de durcir
encore les obligations qui seraient
imposées aux allocataires du RSA est-ce
que vous vous considérez que le texte du
Gouvernement tel qu'il a été présenté
et sur un bon équilibre qu'il faut
conserver
60%
aujourd'hui il y a 60% des bénéficiaires
du RSA qui sont bénéficiaires depuis 5
ans
est-ce que c'est satisfaisant est-ce que
on peut nous se satisfaire du fait que
les personnes la majorité des gens qui
touchent le RSA
soient condamnés à toucher le RSA bien
moi je ne me satisfais pas de ça et donc
le projet que porte le gouvernement
c'est un projet qui vise à accompagner
ces personnes là qui jour après jour
s'éloigne de l'emploi qui jour après
jour s'éloigne de la socialisation qui
jour après jour
s'éloignent finalement de la place
qu'elle doit avoir dans la société et
donc nous devons
les accompagner et leur permettre de
retrouver la place qui donnait à leur
c'est ça le fondement du RSA c'est ça
qu'on a voulu lorsqu'on a créé le RMI
c'était permettre à chacun de retrouver
sa place dans la société et donc cet
accompagnement
cette finalement se sur mesure qu'on va
faire avec chaque personne qui est au
RSA pour lui pour en fonction de la
situation qui est la sienne trouver le
chemin pour la ramener vers l'emploi je
trouve que c'est une formidable mesure
et une formidable mesure sociale que la
gauche devrait applaudir des deux mains
et je ne comprends pas le débat
aujourd'hui tel qu'il se place parce que
nous devrions être tous mobilisés pour
faire en sorte que chaque citoyen de
notre pays puissent avoir pleinement sa
place dans notre société
dernière question on constate au fil des
législatures et des années un désamour
des Français en vis-à-vis des élus en
général mais en particulier vis-à-vis de
la démocratie représentative des députés
est-ce que vous considérez que le taux
de participation au prochain élections
législatives fera partie des critères
qui diront si cette législature si vous
collectivement et individuellement
avaient réussi dans votre mission est-ce
que vous pensez que dans le cadre de
cette assemblée qui parfois dans
laquelle les débats sont parfois
enflammés mais une assemblée qui vit
est-ce que vous considérez ce que vous
espérez pouvoir inverser la tendance
j'espère j'espère que effectivement
l'Assemblée nationale faisant preuve de
son utilité
en fait retrouvera sa place dans le
coeur des Français j'ai aussi toute une
politique d'ouverture que je mène à
l'Assemblée nationale et notamment nous
avons une politique qui vise à doubler
le nombre de citoyens qui viennent
visiter l'Assemblée nationale et je
pense que ça ça participe aussi à
retrouver la confiance et donc en tout
cas je l'espère et le taux de
participation est un indicateur qui peut
s'avérer extrêmement cruel mais qui en
tout cas dans ce qu'il est moi je pense
que c'est très signifiant donc j'espère
alors ce n'est pas ça ne sera pas que
l'effet de la politique et la mienne et
de ce que l'on fait à l'Assemblée mais
en tout cas j'espère que collectivement
on va réussir à revivifier notre vie
démocratique et à retrouver un élan
démocratique dans notre pays on en a
tous besoin
merci madame la présidente de
l'Assemblée d'avoir répondu à nos
questions à bâton rompu merci à tous
d'avoir participé à cette conférence de
presse et bonne après-midi à l'Assemblée
nationale et sur les chaînes
parlementaires merci
[Musique]